I have something very special for you today.
Yes, this is another one of those going down
with the ship appearances by Donald Trump's
press secretary, Kelly McCann, and on Fox
News propagandist Sean Hannity's program.
Yes, Kelly is still pushing debunked voter
fraud claims that no court believes that they
have no evidence for that even Donald Trump
seems to have given up on at this point.
But this clip is special in that it has an
extra element that is really dangerous and
particularly pernicious.
It shows us how lack of just simple mathematical
understanding can be used by people, whether
they understand it or not, to trick others
into believing really stupid things.
Donald Trump's press secretary, Kayleigh McEnany,
in this appearance last night did some of
the typical things.
For example, as usual, she holds up pieces
of paper as if holding up pieces of paper
makes her claims more credible.
Take a look at this is significant, which
is why you have 18 states signing on to this
very well done lawsuit by the state of Texas.
And then she holds up pieces of paper again,
as if they change anything about the fact
that Donald Trump lost and Joe Biden won power.
And because Jake Tapper, fake news, CNN and
others can't wake up and find enough energy
to go read a public court filing, I did it
for them.
You can find the sworn declaration by Charles
Casati, who, by the way, PhD from Rutgers,
tenured professor, expert testimony and hundreds
of court cases goes through meticulously how
he used Z scores and standard deviations from
a medium to come up with this median to come
up with this number.
So it's the job of a reporter to go find this.
It's out there, it's public, and it's a dereliction
of the duty and the job that each of these
reporters have to not look into this, to not
look at the sourcing, which is available for
all to read a sworn declaration.
Whoa, hold on a second here.
Oh, wait a second.
Joe Biden, still one.
Right.
So that's all the stuff we're used to.
But then here comes the dangerous math.
Take a look at this.
Kayleigh McEnany presents the idea that what
took place on election night has only a one
in one quadrillion chance of happening.
And thus there must have been fraud.
Donald Trump must have won.
Now, one quadrillion is a thousand raised
to the power of five or one, followed by 15
zeros.
Sean Hannity asks her, Caylee, how did you
come up with that number?
And she explains, But explain how you got
that number.
Yeah, I'm glad you asked that because you
had fake news.
CNN saying that the affidavits I were showing
were blank when all you had to do was go look
at a public court filing to read them yourselves.
But of course, they couldn't do that.
That's the job of a reporter.
But instead, I'm having to do their job for
them, including with this number.
The stat I gave last night, which is eye opening
and truthful, is that for for President Trump
to be ahead as far as he was at 3:00 a.m.
in these four states, Michigan, Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin, Georgia, and for the vote to swing
by as much as it did, the probability of that
in one state is one in one quadrillion.
That's one comma, 15 zeros to happen in all
four.
It's one comma, 15 zeros to the fourth power.
And because Jake Tapper, fake news, CNN and
others can't wake up and find enough energy
to go read a public court filing, I did it
for them.
So this this the claim it.
So we have to first understand the claim and
then we can we can better examine it.
What she says is the odds of what happened
in some states when they counted ballots,
meaning Trump was winning and then he was
losing as they counted more ballots.
She says the odds of that happening in one
state are one in one quadrillion.
And then she says, and because it happened
in four states, the odds of that happening
in four states are one in one quadrillion
raised to the fourth power.
So let's deal with the second part first,
because it's simpler.
Erick, at one of our viewers, Eric wrote to
me and said, David, do you think she doesn't
realize that that's not how exponents work?
Or do you think she realizes it and is just
lying to people?
I have no idea.
But Eric is right.
If the odds were one in one quadrillion in
one state, you don't just raise that to the
fourth power to calculate the odds of it happening
in four states.
The math doesn't work that way.
Now, let me explain to you what what they're
trying to do here.
And it can be really tough to explain this
stuff.
This will be a nice challenge.
Let's see if I can explain this in a way that's
clear.
In Pennsylvania, the final election results
were Biden 50 percent and Trump forty eight
point eight percent.
Let's just call it for simplicity.
Fifty to forty nine.
OK, now what this one in one quadrillion thing
comes from is imagine for a second that the
results within any slice of Pennsylvania were.
The same or expected to be the same as for
the entire state, so what I mean by that is
Joe Biden won Pennsylvania fifty to forty
nine.
If you expected Joe Biden to win every county
fifty to forty nine and you expected Joe Biden
to win every city fifty to forty nine.
And you expected Joe Biden to win in-person
voting fifty to forty nine and and voting
by fifty to forty nine.
Only if you assume identical distribution
of votes in all locations and all types of
votes.
Only then would you be able to say the odds
of Trump having a hundred thousand several
hundred thousand vote lead on election night
and that lead evaporating as mail in ballots
are counted would be very, very unlikely.
But we know that that's not the case.
For example, in Philadelphia, Biden got eighty
one percent of the vote, Trump only got 18.
And in Philadelphia there were more than 700000
votes.
On the other hand, if you look at as an example,
Clearfield County, Pennsylvania, Trump easily
won Clearfield County with 74 percent of the
vote, but it's a very small number of voters.
It's only forty thousand compared to 700000
in Philadelphia.
If you look at in-person versus mail and in-person
voting was much more skewed to Donald Trump,
mail in voting was much more skewed to Joe
Biden exactly as expected.
So one quadrillion one in one quadrillion
is meaningless.
Once you realize low population red areas
where there was more in-person voting, those
were counted early and they leaned Trump high
population.
Biden areas with more mail and voting were
counted late, both of which we anticipated.
It's not like that's even a surprise.
And once you understand that Cayley saying
one in one quadrillion is instantly nonsense,
it's just meaningless.
But it sounds good to lots of people who don't
understand basic math.
And then, of course, raise it to the fourth
power because we're talking about four states.
That's also garbage.
That's just trash.
So this exemplifies how Trump is get into
much of this nonsense.
They they fall for bogus math.
I don't know if Cayley knows that the math
is garbage and she's lying.
Or maybe Kaylie doesn't even understand the
math.
Doesn't really matter.
The point is Caylee gives a big number and
she used exponents.
So that must mean that Donald Trump actually
won this election.
And, of course, that's garbage.
And this is a prime example of how people
fall for this stuff.
This next story reminds us that it's not
always that elites don't care, that the average
American can't always afford health care or
housing payments or food.
Sometimes they may not know what's going on